[Musik]
Heizung Strom ampelstreit klimaretten
auf die harte Tour einen guten Abend
liebe Zuschauer das ist unser Thema
heute Planwirtschaft staatliche
verbotswut die Pläne von Robert Habeck
zum Verbot von Gas und Ölheizungen haben
nicht nur die Opposition in Rage
versetzt auch Ministerpräsidenten der
SPD protestierten und die FDP will von
allem nichts gewusst haben habe ich
beklagt sich nun über einen
Vertrauensbruch in der Ampel und
befürchtet dass hier Klimaschutz als
Kulturkampf ausgetragen wird und das
alles in einer Woche in der der
Weltklimarat warnt dass der Klimawandel
noch schneller voranschreitet als wir
alle befürchten wir müssen reden mit
diesem Essen
die Vorsitzende von Bündnis 90 die
Grünen Ricarda
der Ministerpräsident von Sachsen
Michael Kretschmer
die Wirtschaftsweise Veronika Grimm
Gerald Trauffer Chef Korrespondent vom
Spiegel
und der Chefredakteur von
finanz-josef Tenhagen
sie sind zu Gast bei Maybrit Illner
[Musik]
und die begrüßt alle Gäste noch mal
ausgesprochen herzlich
verschrottungsorgie formulierte selbst
die FDP in und aus der Ampel die Nerven
liegen blank in genau dieser Koalition
und dabei müsste man sich doch
eigentlich erinnern
auf dem Koalitionsgipfel heute vor einem
Jahr beschloss die Ampel gemeinsam das
Ende der Gasheizung ich bin sehr froh
und dankbar über das Ergebnis ein Jahr
und ein Gesetzentwurf später ist der
Koalitionspartner FDP aufgewacht
klar ist doch das ein zu frühes Verbot
aller Gasheizungen beispielsweise für
die Menschen sozial und wirtschaftlich
nicht verkraftbar ist führende
Sozialdemokraten machen auf
Opposition
ich halte diese Pläne für ungerecht und
unbrauchbar habe es Zeitplanung ist
nicht realistisch und stiftet am Ende
mehr schaden als nutzen
der Kanzler bleibt fröhlich in seiner
Welt
das passiert stattgefunden hat ist ein
sehr fühlbares unterhaken und beim
Vizekanzler kocht die Wärmepumpe es kann
aber nicht sein dass in einer
fortschrittskoalition nur einen
Koalitionspartner für den Fortschritt
verantwortlich ist und die anderen für
die Verhinderung von Fortschritt
Ricarda lange ist bei uns eine der zwei
Parteivorsitzenden Frau Erlangen der
Vizekanzler sagt es gibt einen
Vertrauensbruch innerhalb der Koalition
er unterstellt dass sein Gesetzentwurf
mit Absicht vorzeitig durchgestochen
wurde um Verhandlungen darüber zu
zerstören wie kann man so eigentlich
noch weitere gehen ich glaube wenn man
sich das letzte Jahr anschaut dann haben
wir es immer wieder geschafft als Ampel
auch ein sehr schwierigen Situationen da
kamen einen Krieg auf europäischen Boden
da kam eine Energiekrise gemeinsam
Lösung zu finden und ich bin mir sehr
sehr sicher wir werden das auch dieses
Mal schaffen wir haben allerdings ein
Problem und da rede ich gar nicht über
die Koalition sondern allgemein das
Parteienspektrum wenn seine Aufteilung
gibt wo immer die einen Vorschläge nach
meinem Klimaschutz und die anderen nur
sagen warum das nicht geht dafür ist die
Lage zu ernst das hat diese Woche noch
mal der weltklimaat gezeigt es ist zu
ernst Klimaschutz zu der Aufgabe einer
Partei zu machen und dann bin ich mir
wünschen vielleicht kommen wir in
Zukunft ja dahin dass diejenigen die
sagen so nicht man dann auch sagen was
ist ihre Alternative und dann reden wir
endlich mal über den Weg und über das
Wie und nicht mal was ob SPD und FDP
würden das natürlich mit abschau und
Empörung von sich weisen dass sie nicht
gleichermaßen auch am Klimaschutz ein
Interesse hätten noch mal die Frage wenn
Robert Habeck sagt der andere soll
angeschwärzt werden damit wird Vertrauen
zerstört in die Regierung und das ist in
diesem Fall wahrscheinlich die Absicht
gewesen was heißt das für das Klima in
dieser Regierung ich glaube das ist
jetzt in den letzten Wochen ziemlich
ruppig zugegangen ist das ist keine
Überraschung ich glaube manchmal muss
auch gesagt werden was gesagt werden
muss aber jetzt müssen wir auch
zusammenkommen jetzt müssen uns an Tisch
setzen miteinander verhandeln und zu
einer Einigung kommen wenn ich glaube
das erwarten ehrlich gesagt die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger und das Land hat
ja auch eine Regierung verdient die sich
einen kann die Einigung muss ich dann am
Ende natürlich aber auch an der Realität
der Klimakrise messen lassen und da
reicht es eben nicht nur zu sagen ja wir
sind ja auch für das Ziel wenn wir uns
anschauen dass ich ja alle
demokratischen Parteien Deutschland
verpflichtet haben ist die
Klimaneutralität 2045 wenn ich das
Lernen
keine neuen gassenölheizung die 30 Jahre
genutzt werden einbauen jetzt müssen wir
überlegen wie kriegen wir diese
Generationenaufgabe wärmewende auf den
Weg jetzt müssen wir starten wir reden
unbedingt über das Wie nicht über das ob
Michael Kretschmer ist bei uns der
Ministerpräsident des Freistaates
Sachsen Herr Kretschmer die Grünen sagen
wir müssen alles nachholen was die
Regierung zuvor über 16 Jahre lang hat
schleifen lassen sagen ihnen ihre grünen
das in der Kenia Koalition von Sachsen
ja immer leicht nicht auf andere alles
zu schieben aber die Realität sieht
anders aus Angela Merkel hatte einen
Plan sie hat Experten zusammengerufen
die ähm eine Vorstellung entwickelt
haben wie kann das funktionieren das war
ein aus meiner Sicht sehr plausibler Weg
Braunkohle abzuschalten und damit
von Sachsen durch Garten nein für
Deutschland Gas zu ersetzen Gas hat
Pipeline Gas halb so viel CO2-Ausstoß
wie Braunkohle von daher durchaus
plausibel jetzt gibt es diesen Krieg für
den kann niemand von uns etwas aber wir
müssen damit umgehen und was die Grünen
nicht schaffen ist sich jetzt wirklich
frei zu machen von ihren ideologischen
Vorstellungen die sie hatten und einfach
die Realität zu sehen wie sie ist wir
brauchen einen Neuaufsetzen dieser
Energiewende wenn das so weitergeht
führt das zu Deindustrialisierung und es
ist sehr bitter dass sie sich
miteinander streiten und nicht die
Fähigkeit die Kraft haben einfach anhand
von technischen ökonomischen Realitäten
diese Energiewende neu aufzusetzen und
ich bin da der erste der dabei ist und
auch mithelfen würde ich glaube auch die
Wirtschaftswissenschaften die
ingenieurtechniken alle müssen
zusammenkommen und einen neuen Plan
entwickeln aber das tun sie nicht sie
geben einfach nur mehr Gas und sorgen
dafür dass wir eine Verknappung von
Energie bekommen dass wir mehr CO2
ausstoßen wenn man sich überlegt wie
viele
rotkohlekraftwerke jetzt angeheizt
werden wir haben die League das ist der
braunkohleverstromer in der Lausitzer
1000 neue Mitarbeiter eingestellt weil
sie gesagt haben die alten Kraftwerke
sollen wieder ans Netz jetzt soll die
Atomkraft abgeschaltet werden durch was
wird das ersetzt durch dieses LNG Gas
was genauso viel CO2-Ausstoß wie
Braunkohle und durch Braunkohle das ist
doch keine Klimapolitik das ist eine
Verarschung der jungen Generation den
das wirklich wichtig ist der Klimaschutz
aber ich finde dann müssen wir gerade
ein bisschen jungen Generation hier auch
einmal bei der Wahrheit bleiben warum
müssen wir jetzt so verdammt viel
nachholen warum sind wir so abgehängt im
Vergleich zu anderen Ländern ist z.B
wärmewende geht warum müssen hier in
Deutschland
zehntausende Jobs in der Solarenergie
abgewürgt worden da gab es neue
Arbeitsplätze weil die große Koalition
keinerlei Fokus auf Einstieg in
erneuerbaren Energien gesetzt hat man
hat den Ausstieg geredet und Ausstieg
aus der Kohlen den Ausstieg aus der
Natur man ist aber nicht eingestiegen in
die neue Bahn Energie und das ist es was
am Ende die Industrie und den
Wirtschaftsstandort gefährdet hat und
jetzt müssen das alles aufholen und
ehrlich gesagt wenn sie sagen sie sind
da gerne Teil der Lösung davon sehe ich
wenn ich mir gerade den Wind ausbauen
Sachsen anschaue ehrlich gesagt noch
verdammt wenig Sie bitten immer ein
bisschen anzukommen in der Realität wir
hatten ein Kohlekompromiss der über
Parteigrenzen über alle
gesellschaftlichen Gruppen vereinbart
worden ist dann gab es diesen
furchtbaren und gibt es diesen
furchtbaren Krieg und wir wissen dass
jetzt Gas in der Form nicht mehr zur
Verfügung steht noch einmal ich sag's
noch einmal Pipeline Gas hatte halb so
viel CO2 wiegt Braunkohle es war
plausibel diesen Weg zu gehen eine
Brüchen Brückentechnologie zu machen das
geht jetzt nicht mehr das akzeptiere ich
erkenne ich an ich habe eine Meinung zu
Nord Stream 1 aber das ist jetzt eine
andere Frage was aber nicht geht ist in
dieser Tagen aus der Atomenergie
auszusteigen wissend dass das für die
nächsten Jahre nur mit mehr CO2
Anschluss geht das ist das was sie jetzt
unmittelbar tun und worüber wir uns
jetzt gerade unterhalten ist sind
technologische Herausforderungen man
kann nicht von heute auf morgen alle
Gasheizungen alle Ölheizungen wegmachen
man braucht einen Pfad dafür weil weder
die Kapazitäten da sind noch die die
Geräte in der vernünftigen
Preiskategorie es braucht seine Zeit wir
sind ganz kurz mitten in der Debatte und
ich mache noch mal den kleinen Hinweis
worauf Frau lang eigentlich abzielte
fünf Windräder sind im letzten Jahr
gebaut worden in Sachsen von können Sie
auch andere Bundesländer nehmen
baden-55 Windrädern sind entschuldigung
ich muss mich korrigieren im ganzen Jahr
11 also 2 % Sachsen von 551 warum
schließlich weil wir weil wir eine
Bevölkerung haben die das nicht für
richtig hält und es war aus meiner Sicht
notwendig ein neues Energie und
klimaprogramm zu machen das haben wir
werden die Bauordnung geändert ich finde
es gibt richtige Entscheidungen auch in
der Bundesregierung eine Beteiligung der
Kommunen jetzt an den Erträgen nein um
einfach die Akzeptanz zu erhöhen und
jetzt muss man diesen Weg auch
weitergeben und auch da ich bin nicht
total dabei nur es muss aber Folgendes
sagen wenn wir diesen windausbau jetzt
machen oder solarausbau ist das doch
keine Frage von heute auf morgen man
braucht doch fünf oder zehn Jahre und
deswegen ist es doch jetzt wirklich
falsch die Dinge so zu überstürzen dass
wir eine dirndustrialisierung in den
nächsten Jahren haben werden und dann
wirklich nicht mehr auf die Beine kommen
als Deutschland auch das werden wir uns
merken und gehen noch mal einen kleinen
Schritt zurück sind dankbar dass Gerald
drauf hätte bei uns ist
chefkorrespondent Hauptstadtstudio
Spiegel Herr Trauffer wir haben einen
Gesetzentwurf einen Referentenentwurf
präsentiert bekommen vor vier Wochen das
war offensichtlich seitens des
Bundeswirtschaftsministers ungewollt und
dennoch ist über vier Wochen über diesen
Referentenentwurf spekuliert worden
zunächst gleich das Verbot
vier Wochen später die Details der
Hilfen der Unterstützung ist das
wenigstens kommunikativ eine
Vollkatastrophe also das kann man
getrost sagen das war eine
volkatastrophe ich hatte natürlich den
Ausgang in diesem League das hat der
Airbag beklagt das ist natürlich für den
Minister schwer wenn er dann ein Entwurf
der noch nicht richtig fertig ist auf
einmal in der Öffentlichkeit
rechtfertigen muss aber was natürlich
dann geschah war für das Anliegen auch
für den Klimaschutz für das Land fatal
denn es wurde zwar redet was eigentlich
wirklich ganz ganz wichtig ist das
nämlich diese wärmewende voran kommt und
da hatte ganz viele in der haben ganz
viele in der Koalition keine Disziplinen
gehabt meine dass der Kretschmer dass
die Oppositionen das aufgreift als
dankbares
als dankbaren Spielball das ist klar
aber dass dann die die eigene Koalition
dann über habe ich herfällt das war
natürlich das war natürlich ein Fehler
und sie hätten natürlich sofort
reagieren müssen das hätten natürlich
sofort ganz konkret die sozialen Hilfen
genannt werden müssen die Härtefälle die
man da berücksichtigen will und und
sagen müssen bitte diskutiert nicht
darüber also sofort sagen müssen das ist
ein Frühchen das ist ein
vorreferentenentwurf es ist eben noch
nicht das was wir euch jetzt im Grunde
schon vorlegen aber leider hat natürlich
der Koalitionspartner mit harten Worten
verbotsstrategie und so weiter da
natürlich so eine Art Opposition
gespielt und es ist doch offensichtlich
auch so gemeint oder wollen Sie uns mal
aufklären Frau lang ist das jetzt soll
das so kommen ja oder nein
gerne aufklären es wird keine
verschrottungsorgie geben den ganzen
Gegenteil wer bisher eine Öl- oder
Gasheizung hat der wird ja auch in 2024
und 2025 darüber hinaus weiter betreiben
können wenn neu gebaut wird oder wenn
die Gasheizung oder die Ölheizung
vollkommen Geist aufgibt nicht mehr
repariert werden kann und eine neue
Heizung eingebaut wird dann ist es doch
eigentlich ein Gebot der Vernunft dass
ich nicht auf fossile Technologien die
auf Dauer auf einem teuersten Sätze
sondern sich auf bezahlbare und
erneuerbare Energienetze und nichts
anderes geht es aber ja es stimmt das
muss sozial abgefedert werden das muss
sozial abgefedert werden Vermieterinnen
Mieter die sich zwar dauerhaft auf
bezahlbare Rechnungen belassen können
die natürlich nicht alle Kosten
umgelagert bekommen das muss sozial
abgefedert werden für Vermieter da
wollen wir vor allem auch mit
Steuererleichterungen arbeiten und für
Eigenheimbesitzer mit wenig Geld das ist
gezogen brauchen
zu den politischen vorlaut dieser ganzen
Affäre es war glaube ich ein ganz
schwerer strategischer Fehler jetzt von
Habeck dass er dass er da so
losgeschlagen hat denn er war eigentlich
immer darauf bedacht eben nicht in der
Regierung zu opponieren er hat das an
der FDP kritisiert zurecht und jetzt hat
er auf einmal diese Rolle auch
eingenommen und das war glaube ich ein
Fehler er hat das wahrscheinlich gemacht
weil in der Partei so viel Druck war
weil er glaube ich da mal irgendwie ein
Zeichen setzen wollte in die Partei
hinein aber eigentlich will Herr Berg
aus den Grünen eine Volkspartei machen
und da war glaube ich diese Auftritte in
den Tagesthemen in großer Fehler noch
gar nicht geredet haben wir über die SPD
Veronika Grimm ist gleich dran Frau lang
aber danach unbedingt noch eine Frage
die Ministerpräsidenten protestieren
nicht einfach so sondern die Pläne sind
ungerecht und unbrauchbar ähnlich wie
Herr Kretschmer die Zeitplanung ist
unrealistisch und stiftet mehr Schaden
als Nutzen
ärgern Sie sich über die mehr oder über
den Bundeskanzler der immer noch
schweigt der Olaf Scholz könnte ja auch
einfach mal was sagen ich würde sagen
Ministerpräsidenten empfehlen Paula
Scholz anzurufen oder Clara Gallwitz die
mit uns gemeinsam diesen Beschluss
gefasst haben ich glaube nochmal zu der
Frage des ungerechten da müssen wir auch
sehen es ist eine Frage von
Bezahlbarkeit der Preis für fossiles Gas
wird in den nächsten Jahren nicht
runtergehen sondern der wird allein
schon durch den Zertifikatehandel weite
hochgehen
ist das unbezahlbar
reden wir auf jeden Fall drüber Januar
2014/2024 da wird für Neubauten der
Einbau von Öl und Gas Heizungen
untersagt es geht doch nicht
realistisch sehen was an Technik da ist
was die kostet was die Handwerker machen
Veronika Grimm sie ist Wirtschaftsweise
sie hat sogar in der Gaspreise
Kommission mit gesessen und uns geholfen
eben über diese harte Zeit des letzten
Jahres zu kommen auch darüber muss man
eigentlich noch reden und sie sind
Energie Expertin kein wenn sich so gut
aus mit allem was wir an Energie in
diesem Land haben sie sind Frau Grimm
explizit gegen das Verbot von
Gasheizungen ab dem 1 Januar 2024 ja
zunächst man ja mal sagen das ist ja
kein vollständiges Verbot sondern es
wurde richtig gesagt das sind
Anforderungen an Heizungen die in Neubau
Bestand installiert werden die relativ
ambitioniert sind die eigentlich
Lösungen außer der Wärmepumpe weitgehend
ausschließen es sei denn es gibt
Fernwärme die aber ich würde mal ganz
woanders anfangen ich würde mal ganz
woanders anfangen nämlich wenn man jetzt
wirklich überlegt wie wollen wir es
schaffen unsere Klimaziele zu erreichen
dann ist meine Diagnose eigentlich mit
diesem Instrument werden wir es nicht
schaffen weil wir uns an den Rand das
Nervenzusammenbruch bringen werden und
zwar deswegen weil man sehr viele
Menschen mit alten Heizungen die
durchschnittliche Gasheizung 17 Jahre
alt
ich glaube 20% sind älter als
25 Jahre das heißt es gibt relativ viele
Leute die ihre Heizung weit austauschen
müssen viele davon kaufen jetzt erstmal
schnell noch eine Gasheizung und
versuchen die einzubauen das ist auch
kein besonders wünschenswerter Effekt
Fachkräftemangel haben wir das heißt wir
werden sogar noch 600.000 wir werden gar
nicht so schnell schaffen so viele
Heizungen einzubauen und dann ist
natürlich richtig es ist eine Frage das
Geldes die Wärmepumpen sind extrem teuer
ich glaube auch dass die Preise massiv
untertrieben werden die da gerade die da
gerade so behandelt gehandelt werden
20.000 €, also was man von den
Heizungsbauern hört ist eher 60.000 €
all together und wenn die Nachfrage
richtig ansteigt und die Fachkräfte
knapp werden ist das natürlich eine
Hausnummer die man sich dann auch
vorstellen muss und das sind dann auch
Kosten wenn man das entlassen will jetzt
kann man sagen man macht's nur bei den
echt Bedürftigen aber wie identifiziere
ich die ich habe ein riesigen
bürokratischen Aufwand für die zu in
identifizieren im Endeffekt muss ich
dann wieder mit der Gießkanne fördern
und das wird der Staat an die Reden auf
jeden Fall und Unterteil von wir laufen
in einer Situation die einfach nicht
funktionieren kann man muss den Übergang
anders gestalten es gibt den Vorschlag
eines co2-preises den man zumindest
einführen könnte um den Druck zu
erzeugen dann würden nämlich die die das
Geld haben wissen ich muss hier in die
richtige Richtung investieren und dann
kann man altern darauf überlegen wie
hilft man denen die sich das nicht
leisten können und es käme dann eben
nicht plötzlich sondern es würde ein
Übergang sein und wer dann eine
Gasheizung sich jetzt noch installiert
weil er vielleicht einfach sieht ich
habe jetzt keine anderen Alternativen
der steigt dann vielleicht früher um der
muss die eben später die mit der müsste
eben dann früher wieder austauschen oder
er wechselt auf klimafreundlich egal
also das kann eben auch eine Option sein
nicht für viele aber eben doch eine von
vielen
Optionen weil also ich meine wir tun
hier so als sei das mit diesen
Wärmepumpen also sowas grandios Neues
und Unbekanntes weil in unbekannte
Welten wie wir hier Vordringen in
Schweden ist das ist das ein das
wärmemittel die die Heizung eine normale
zu ziehen Schweden hat seine Wärmenetze
ausgebaut seit Jahren seit mehr als 10
Jahren Schweden hat ein CO2-Preis
eingeführt schon in den 90er Jahren der
ist jetzt bei 110 € und Schweden hat
sich gut vorbereitet Schweden hat noch
die Kernkraft und hat Wasserkraft und
billigen Strom bereitzustellen Schweden
ist einfach kein guter Vergleich und zu
sagen wir machen das jetzt einfach ganz
genauso die sind besser vorbereitet
gewesen die haben mehr Fernwärmenetze in
allen Städten auch das ist bei uns nicht
der Fall insofern sind diese Vergleiche
hinten auch so ein bisschen und ich
glaube wir müssen uns da auch ehrlich
machen
zusammen zu fassen
noch mal die grundsätzliche Frage zu
stellen Frau lang also
in neun Monaten werden Besitzer von
Neubauten gezwungen sein keine Öl und
keine Gasheizungen einzubauen sondern im
allerbesten Fall Wärmepumpen ab 1.12 24
das ist ja sehr schnell wenn man sich
neun Monate wenn man sich eine
Wärmepumpe bestellen möchte braucht man
durchschnittlich 10 bis 14 Monate um die
auszusuchen zu Genehmigung in beraten zu
haben da gibt es schon die erste
Kollision also Frage Nummer eins warum
setzen Sie ein solches Datum wohl
wissend in welcher technischen Lage
dieses Land gerade ist in welcher
Material und technischen Lage das ist
Frage Nummer eins was würden Sie sagen
es kommt direkt noch Fragen Nummer zwei
natürlich ich habe gerade schon gesagt
wenn wir 20:45 Uhr ernst meinen dann
können wir auch im Jahr 2025 20 26 in
Neubauten nicht immer noch auf Öl und
Gasheizung setzen das ist ja schon rein
mathematisch die haben eine
Halbwertszeit von 30 Jahren dann bin ich
weit über 20 45 das heißt wir müssen da
jetzt rangehen ankurbeln in der
Umsetzung gerne pragmatisch sie haben es
gerade angesprochen im Bestand ist jetzt
schon vorgesehen dass man auch andere
Technologien machen kann ich glaube
nicht dass die Zukunft in der
wasserstoffheizung liegt weil a das
ziemlich ziemlich teuer sein wird auch
auf Dauer und wir B Wasserstoff brauchen
für klimaneutralen Stahl für den Umbau
der Chemieindustrie aber wer das am Ende
machen will der kann das auch machen das
heißt da flexibel Übergangsfristen und
die finanzielle Unterstützung wird der
Kernpunkt sein und das kann ich
versprechen wenn die Regel kommt dann
wird sie sozial flankiert sein dann wird
auch die soziale Flankierung stehen ich
würde aber wenn ich dürfte einmal auf
dieses Preis-Argument eingehen weil
tatsächlich ist das ja wirklich eine
spannende Debatte das finde ich auch ich
habe ja vorher gesagt man sollte über
Alternativen reden und das ist ja
interessante ich bin davon überzeugt
Klimakrise ist zu ernst als dass wir uns
auf einen ins du Instrument beschränken
können sondern wir werden die
unterschiedlichen Instrumente brauchen
und ich glaube dass der Preis auch ein
zentrales ist auch wenn ich auf den
Bereich Wärme schaue
Zertifikate Handeln in Europa was dann
hier sozusagen auch untergebrochen
werden kann mit dem CO2-Preis das sind
aber finde ich zwei Dinge zu beachten
und das eine ist der Markt gibt Signale
aber was ist wenn die Signal zu spät
kommen also wenn ich mir zum Beispiel im
Jahr 2026 weil es billiger ist eine
Gasheizung einbaue statt einer
Wärmepumpe zehn Jahre später ist der
Preis massiv hochgegangen ich stehe dann
da mit dieser Gasheizung kann meine
Gasrechnung nicht mehr bezahlen in dem
Moment wird ja die eigentlich
intensierte Lenkungswirkung zu einer
Strafe Wirkung das heißt da brauche ich
dramatischen Situation wenn ich
antizipiere dass wenn ich z.B über so
ein CO2 Zertifikate handelt jetzt das
Wort hier und frühzeitig sage ich
etabliere das jetzt und setze durch den
Zertifikate Handel die
Emissionsreduktionsziele eigentlich
durch ja dann gibt es eine Menge an
Emissionen die noch imitiert werden
dürfen und die werden dann über
Zertifikate gehandelt und man kann schon
navigieren das ist eben sehr teuer
werden wird wenn ich mir eine Gasheizung
habe und das werden natürlich das werden
natürlich die Unternehmen antizipieren
weil die ja diejenigen sind die die
Geräte ihren Kunden verkaufen müssen und
natürlich wird die Antizipation von
hohen Preisen hohen Betriebskosten was
auslösen bei den Unternehmen wird
nämlich sehen dass man seine Anlagen
nicht mehr los wird und die
Energieberater sehen das natürlich auch
und können natürlich den Vergleich
ziehen schau mal Strom wird günstiger
Gas wird perspektivisch sehr teuer und
ich glaube schon dass man da den Preis
nehmen kann und durchaus eben flankieren
kann ich glaube man muss durchaus viele
komplementäre Instrumente für die CO2
Steuer oder Fernwärme und so weiter aber
ich glaube das ist schon ganz wichtiges
Element so er trifft ich würde gerne
noch eine Frage loswerden bevor wir eben
über diese Preisgestaltung von
Wärmepumpen überhaupt noch mal kurz
reden können damit die Zuschauer das
auch verstehen was jetzt geschieht ist
Menschen überlegen also Eigentümer
überlegen wo sie Kredite herbekommen es
gibt Eigentümer Gemeinschaften die jetzt
schon überlegen wie sie übermorgen
klären wenn eine Pumpe kaputt geht eine
Therme kaputt geht was sie dann in einem
Mehrfamilienhaus als
Eigentümergemeinschaft entscheiden
Immobilien verlieren ihren Wert weil sie
eben mit einer schlechteren Heizung
ausgestattet sind und Mieter zittern was
löst also die Menschen werden jetzt
schön miteinander gegeneinander
geschickt in dieser Situation
also Wärme ist ein Urbedürfnis des
Menschen und das da natürlich sofort
irgendwie Gefühle aufkommen wenn darüber
geredet wird das ist auf jeden Fall sehr
verständlich aber man muss glaube ich da
so ein bisschen Ordnung reinbringen ähm
es gibt den einen Fall eben für neue
Bauten da ist es so dass jetzt
tatsächlich die Wärmepumpe als eine
Lösung der Wahl angesehen wird die ist
zwar teuer aber das muss man auch dazu
sagen die wird sich in der Zukunft
rechnen denn man kann nur jedem davon
abraten jetzt noch ganz schnell sich
eine Gasheizung zu kaufen vor allem auch
wenn ich in einem Neubau bin der ja auch
schon sehr gut isoliert ist und Frau
Grimm ist es gibt ja jetzt schon ein
CO2-Preis auf Öl und Gas und es wird
dann in 2027 noch mal einen Schritt
geben wo dann die ja der nicht erholen
würde aber es wird dann die schon genau
dann kommt der Emissionshandel der
Europäischen Union der dann auch im
Wärmemarkt greifen wird und dann werden
die Preise noch mal von Gas auch teurer
werden die Leute doch jetzt
die sich in eigenen Plan machen es ist
eigentlich dieses Gegenteil von
Planwirtschaft alle werden
man muss eben auch sagen dass wir viel
Geld dadurch verschwenden dadurch wird
eben das ganze sehr ineffizient weil mir
die Leute jetzt unmittelbar zur
Entscheidungen trifft diese
Übergangslösungen sind ja auch so dass
man sich dann Übergangsperiode drei
Jahre eine Heizung einbauen soll die man
dann wieder ausbauen soll und ersetzen
soll das sind ja alles zusätzliche
Kosten die auch abgefedert werden müssen
die auch jemand tragen muss und man muss
ja schon sehen wir haben massive Kosten
zu stemmen die Energiewende ist teuer
Verteidigung Rente es gibt viele
Ausgaben die anstehen und wir müssen
schon schauen dass wir das so effizient
und so günstig wie möglich hinbekommen
weil sonst wird es einfach für die
Menschen und letztlich auch für den
Staat der dann entlasten will nicht mehr
bezahlen aber das ist ja tatsächlich
auch der zweite Punkt bei der ganzen
Preis Debatte wenn ich nur über den
Preis geben wird es unglaublich schnell
sozial ungerecht weil nein
außer und da kommen wir dann vielleicht
wieder zusammen wenn wir einkaufen
genau das ist glaube ich ein ganz
zentrale Punkte mehr hinbekommen genau
wir brauchen arzttermechanismus das
Klima Geld dann kann ich nämlich
aufsteigende Preise sehr genau
finanzielle also man etabliert den
CO2-Handel und gibt das Geld pro Kopf an
die Menschen zurück und dann bedeutet es
nämlich dass die Armen die ihren
geringeren CO2-Ausstoß verursachen die
müssen weniger zahlen weil sie weniger
getroffen werden von dem CO2-Preis und
die kriegen dann pro Kopf das gleiche
zurück wie die Reichen und deswegen
verdienen die im Schnitt noch im Modell
wäre auch über so etwas nachzudenken wie
eine CO2 Bepreisung die in diesem Land
leben eine Heizung haben kleines
Eigenheim haben und kleine Wohnung haben
denken wenn sie Menschen sehen die mit
einer großen Begeisterung darüber
erzählen wie das alles teurer wird und
das ist alles so sein muss ich finde es
ist so an den Realitäten vorbei und wenn
es geplant das ist Planwirtschaft und
ehrlich gesagt ich habe das erlebt 40
Jahre lang wie Planwirtschaft
funktioniert es wird nicht funktionieren
sie reden völlig an den technischen
Gegebenheiten voraus und Sie können
vorbei sie können nicht ein politisch
entscheiden irgendwie physikalische
Gesetze und Naturgesetze das geht schief
und wir müssen noch mal sagen es geht
nicht um das Gerät was da hinten steht
und das 2-3000 Euro kostet eine
Wärmepumpenanlage kostet mehrere 10.000
Euro das ist ein großer Unterschied zu
einer Gasheizung und was hier versucht
wird ist muss scheitern und sie haben
das richtig gesagt die Leute drehen
durch die machen zu und wir verlieren
sie auf dem Weg hin die richtigen
Entscheidungen zu treffen den Weg
mitzugehen es gibt eine
Führungsgröße das heißt CO2 Vermeidung
und es gibt einen Weg der dafür sorgt
dass mit Innovation mit Wettbewerb und
auch eine gewissen zeitlichen Vorlauf
das ganze passiert und das ist der CO2
Preis und dann wird es sich alles was
sie tun sorgt dafür mit jeder
Restriktion das Innovationen langsam das
Innovationen wegfallen dass das Denken
über Möglichkeiten sie sorgen dafür dass
immer immer weiter mit Verboten und
geboten eingeengt wird ich finde das
cool wirklich wenn ich das sage und das
Ganze zum ersten Januar das es ist so
unmöglich und ich bin froh darüber dass
das in der Zeitung steht damit die Leute
jetzt auch mal sagen können nein das
machen wir so nicht mit und wenn die
Ministerpräsidenten in Deutschland Ihnen
sagen so geht es nicht dann sollten Sie
darüber nachdenken weil das sind
Menschen die auch Verantwortung tragen
wir sind ein förderales Land und Sie
können hier nicht bei order die Muffin
die Dinge machen sondern sie sollten auf
die hören die in diesem Land auch
Verantwortung tragen also wir können
Gesetze beschließen wir reden darüber
natürlich mit den Ministerpräsidenten
ich glaube das ist
Selbstverständlichkeit in dem föderalen
System aber ich glaube jetzt ehrlich wir
brauchen eine andere ernsthaftigkeiten
dieser Debatte es kann nicht sein dass
sie sich hier hinstellen oder ein
Vorschlag den können sie schlecht finden
dass sie als Opposition schlecht finden
machen Sie gerne besseren zu sagen es
soll nicht teurer werden aber jetzt hier
zwei Personen steigen ist dann nicht so
in sich logisch aber machen Sie gerne
besseren Vorschlag aber gerade mit der
Geschichte in diesem Land haben ein
Vorschlag jemand blöd findet der eine
Regelung vorzieht für eine Neubau und
von Austausch als Planwirtschaft zu
bezeichnen
dieser ganzen Debatte Historie unser
die sich damit auskennen die Techniker
die Handwerker die Leute aus der
Wirtschaft sehen ist genauso
Leute hören mit irgendwelchen
Kulturkampf Debatten um sich sondern die
Reden darum was die beste Lösung ist
schattieren zum Kulturkampf zu
verfeinern machen
ich habe deutlich gesagt welche
Heizungen ja richtig und zwar deswegen
weil
große Koalition weil Gas wesentlich
weniger CO2 hat als Öl und noch einmal
ich bin sehr bereit dazu über ein neues
Konzept der Energiewende zu sprechen das
jetzige ist gescheitet die Parameter die
dem zugrunde lagen gibt es so nicht mehr
wir müssen jetzt neu anfangen das erste
was Sie tun müssen ist den Atomausstieg
zu verhindern sind jeden Tag fünf bis
sechs Prozent der Stromleistung
Deutschland warum wird das jetzt auf äh
beendet und mit CO2 ersetzt erklären sie
das in Leuten sagen das also ich habe so
ein bisschen die Befürchtung dass wir
genau da wieder sind wo wir vor vier
Wochen waren das nämlich jetzt eine ganz
wilde Diskussion anfängt wo ganz
komplizierte Begriffe Fachbegriffe in
den Raum geworfen werden und seit Wochen
und Monaten diskutiert das ist das ist
klar aber da haben sich Mehrheiten Herr
Kretschmer haben sich dagegen
entschieden weiter Atom auf Atomen zu
setzen
Mehrheiten haben sich eigentlich auch
vom Fracking verabschiedet deshalb
setzen wir auf alternative und eben
Elektro am liebsten grünen Elektro
betriebene Pumpen und Heizungen wirklich
wirklich also wo ich wirklich waren
würde vorher ist jetzt so eine
Verwirrung zu stiften dass man am Ende
die Leute denken irgendwie die
Wärmepumpe ist irgendwie das Teufels die
Wärmepumpe hat dann würde ich sagen
dieser Eindruck ist aber dieser Eindruck
ist aber entstanden jetzt in dieser
Diskussion
zu Hause eine
Wärmepumpenanlage vor einem halben Jahr
installiert deswegen kann ich in die
Effizienz sagen ich kann dir sagen wir
würden das genauso wieder machen ich
kann Ihnen die Preise sagen und wir
reden nicht über 5000 10.000 20.000 €.
ich weiß genau
und wir reden genau darüber und dann
kann man noch mal seine persönlichen
Erfahrungen schildern und deshalb
marschiere ich jetzt zu ihm und wir
gucken liebe Zuschauer ganz kurz noch
mal was ich an Fakten zusammentragen
lässt zum Thema was käme mit einer
Wärmepumpe an Kosten auf Sie zu
eine einfache Luftwärmepumpe kostet bis
zu 15.000 Euro eine aufwendigere
Erdwärmepumpe mindestens das Doppelte
nur zum Vergleich eine neue Öl- oder
Gasheizung kostet ca 10.000 Euro
. soll die Wärmepumpe auch in Altbauten
funktionieren kommen Kosten für Dämmung
von Dach und Fassade hinzu
die Wärmepumpe verbraucht auch deutlich
mehr Strom als eine Gasheizung das macht
bei einem Haus mit 150 Quadratmetern
Wohnfläche zusätzlich ca 2000 € pro Jahr
vermieter dürfen ihre Investitionskosten
teilweise umlegen das bedeutet auch die
Miete wird teurer
nehmen wir erstmal die soziale Frage und
versuchen es mit dieser wie sollen
einkommensschwache Menschen wie sollen
alte Menschen ihr Haus irgendwann mit
einer Wärmepumpe ausstatten alte Leute
kriegen keinen Kredit wie sollte es
gehen wenn alte Leute eine Heizung
austauschen müssen weil sie kaputt ist
müssen sie das ohnehin das sind 15000 10
15000 €, wenn es in der wenn Sie eine
Wärmepumpe installieren ist jetzt schon
die Fördersituation so dass sie 40%
Zuschuss bekommen würden wenn die jetzt
14 % von 35 25 oder 30 000 kostet dann
sind Sie bei 16 oder 17000 wenn das dann
sozial abgefedert wird ist das zu machen
wobei für alte Leute da können sie jeder
jede Wohnungs wohneigentümergemeinschaft
tragen wenn sie Senioren da drin haben
und sie wollen was Größeres machen haben
Sie immer ein Problem das heißt das
Problem ist nicht die Wärmepumpe das
Problem ist nicht mal diese neue
Regelung sondern das Problem ist
Senioren die das nicht gut bezahlen
können Teil 1 Teil 2
es gibt daneben für Leute die wohlhabend
sind die Möglichkeit über Jahre
die energetische Sanierung zu machen an
Ihrem Haus und das jeweils bei der
Steuer anzugeben und 60 Prozent 20
Prozent von dem von der Steuer Abzug von
der Steuerschuld abzuziehen also bis zu
40.000 € über die Jahre das ist für
Leute die wohl haben sind eine gute
Möglichkeit und das gibt drittens
natürlich die voll Sanierung da kann man
bei der KfW in Kredit aufnehmen und kann
können 100 oder 150 000 € da ausgeben
das ist aber der Ausnahmefall das heißt
der wichtigste Fall ist dass man jetzt
schon 40% da bekommen kann das ist nicht
aus aber alle
bekäme jeder der das jetzt machen würde
was nicht was der Kretschmer genau
gemacht hat aber normal aber ich würde
annehmen auch in Sachsen ist das so ähm
Energieberater sollte Ihnen das auch
gesagt haben und sie sollten das
hoffentlich bekommen haben wenn nicht
sprechen sie noch mal mit ihrem
Energieberater so das ist das Wichtigste
aber das Problem keine soziale
immer noch 15.000 Euro haben und man
braucht bei einer werbepumpe auch das
ist wichtig zu erwähnen im Grunde auch
eine in Altbauten eine dämm eine
zusätzliche Dämmung der Punkt ist der
Punkt ist von der Punkt ist der die
Wärmepumpe heizt ja diese diesen
altbauauf wenn der Altbau viel viel
Energie braucht weil er nicht gedämmt
ist ist das eine sehr teure
Angelegenheit deswegen wird immer gesagt
erstens man muss den eigentlich dem
zweitens eigentlich versucht man mit
einer Wärmepumpe möglichst große
Heizkörper zu haben das damit man nicht
so viel die werden damit diese
Heizkörper nicht so heiß werden müssen
und trotzdem die Wärme abgeben könnte
dann braucht man weniger Strom da gibt's
ja um die 2000 € sonst ist man nachher
bei 4000 € mit dem Strom also es gibt da
schon technische Voraussetzung aber in
wenn man den Strich drunter macht ist es
so dass es die einzig vernünftige Lösung
im Augenblick ist das so zu machen so
vernünftig heißt noch nicht das ist
notwendig machbar ist dann ist die erste
Frage gibt's hinreichend Anlagen sie
haben gerade gesagt 10 12 14 Monate der
Ex sagt die sind alle da weiß ich nicht
wenn Sie alle da sind würde ich das
Problem mal abhacken wenn Sie nicht da
sind kann man natürlich so ein Termin
nicht halten und Punkt zweitens gibt die
das größere Problem ist aber die Frage
der Handwerker die haben 2021 bei 70
Prozent aller Wohnungen noch Gasheizung
neu eingebaut damals gab es die
Wärmepumpe auch schon damals gab es die
Förderung auch schon warum die
Handwerker das damals gemacht haben da
kann man noch mal eine Frage nachstellen
das ist ein Problem das muss man
natürlich ändern und wenn die müssen
rumkommen und das tun wenn die zwei
jetzt erstmal geschult habe
ich annehmen dass jeder Handwerker der
40 ist also Klempner der sollte wissen
wie eine Wärmepumpe funktioniert sollte
die anstatt bringen können sonst haben
wir da bei der Ausbildung ein
fundamental problem aber glaube ich weil
in der Ausbildung Wärmepumpen
tatsächlich viel zu wenig eine Rolle
spielen fahren Sie fort und dann ist der
letzte Punkt wenn wir die Handwerker
nicht haben oder zu weniger haben ist
natürlich das Verschieben von 2024 auf
20 25 auch keine Lösung wenn man jetzt
fundamental sagt also diese Regierung
hatte sich ja darauf geeinigt 2025
ursprünglich damit anzufangen und dann
hat man wegen des Krieges gesagt wir
ziehen das vor auf 2024 wenn wir LNG
Terminals schnell machen können können
wir auch Gasheizung schnell machen
vielleicht geht das nicht so einfach
aber im Prinzip muss man es vorziehen
weil man kann nicht 20 25 die Handwerker
die man nicht da doppelt so viel Heizung
bauen lassen jemand 20 24 nicht gebaut
hat das wird so nicht funktioniert also
muss man so gucken wie schnell so
schnell wie möglich das auch wirklich zu
machen und dann jetzt ist der letzte
Punkt die Energiekosten die werden
natürlich raufgehen man kann frau Grimm
hat ja recht die in den letzten zwei
Jahren sind die Energiekosten immer
subventioniert worden wir haben alle
gesehen da ist sozusagen wegen des
Krieges und wegen anderer Geschichten
ist der Spritpreis gesehen Energiekosten
subventioniert worden statt
Energiekosten wirken zu lassen und Leute
dann sozusagen noch schneller in diese
Entscheidung rein
und deswegen und deswegen ist das
natürlich ein Problem wenn sie sagen sie
wollen jetzt die Kosten erhöhen wir
haben wir haben dieses Problem ja gehabt
und wir haben die Leute wir haben
beschlossen die Politik hat beschlossen
das können die Bürger nicht tragen diese
höheren Kosten wenn sie jetzt sagen
höhere Kosten sollen aber das das
Instrument sein dass die Bürger dazu
bringen soll dann finde ich dann weiß
ich nicht ganz genau wie das
funktioniert soll also es sind dann auf
jeden Fall aber vielleicht nicht gleich
15000 € die man ja zur Verfügung haben
müsste um eine solche Investition zu
tätigen
noch mal wenn ich die halt wenn die
Heizung kaputt ist wenn die sind ja dann
nur halb so teuer die Gasheizung kostet
auch 15000 oder 10 bis 15.000
Wärmepumpe habe und die Kosten 30 und
ich muss die Hälfte die Hälfte vom Staat
dann bin ich beim gleichen Preis der tut
sich nicht viel und noch zwei Jahren bei
den Kosten die sie im Augenblick haben
für Gas sind sie da schon drüber okay
gemacht
ist gerade auch nicht wenig teuer diese
Investition plus Dämmung plus vielleicht
leitungsneubau da kommen wir schon in
eine Größenordnung wo den Leuten ein
bisschen Klammer aufs Herz wird und auch
den Menschen die das eben die in einem
Häusel wohnen um sich eine Mietzahlung
zu sparen und es wie beschrieben eben
sich gerade so leisten können Mieter
sind noch mal in einer ganz anderen
Situation darüber haben wir jetzt noch
gar nicht gesprochen davon gibt es in
Deutschland ganz viele die Eigentümer ja
die kriegen in die kriegen jetzt eben
diesen modernisierungsabschlag von 8%
darf ja erhöht werden die Miete eben
weil eine Investition dann durch den
Eigentümer stattgefunden hat damit
können Mieter im Grunde jetzt auch schon
rechnen das ist eine Mietsteigerung gibt
vom vermutlich wobei man dann immer
gucken müsste wie viel von dem ist
Modernisierung und wie viel ist
Sanierung
was alles was entstanden ist und
Sanierung ist ja sozusagen schon
abgegolten das kann er nicht unbedingt
nur den Modernisierung und das ist dann
interessante Frage an den Gesetzentwurf
wie man das definiert wann wann es
Sanierung ist und wann ist
Modernisierung ist all das steht
übrigens
toll dass Sie mit dabei sind sie kommen
mit in die Runde wir sind Frau lang bei
dir genau der Frage Herr Kretschmer
erzählt gleich seinen persönliches
erfahren wir sind bei der Frage wem
wollen sie jetzt mehr Sorgen aufbürden
den Eigentümern oder den Mietern indem
man diese Investitionen zu einer
Instandhaltung oder zu einer
Modernisierung erklärt wissen wir das
schon hat die Regierung darüber schon
mal nachgedacht wird das eine
Modernisierung einer jeden Wohnung eines
Hauses oder ist das eine Instandhaltung
und kann also nicht umgelegt werden auf
die Miete also erstens will und werde
ich diese Gruppen nicht gegeneinander
ausspielen zweitens kommt das ja darauf
an was gemacht wird im Haus also wird
einfach nur die Heizung ausgetauscht
oder geht es tatsächlich mit einer
Modernisierung auch andere Strukturen
einher und drittens kann man beiden
helfen indem man bei Mieterinnen und
Mietern und wie gesagt die haben ja
bisher gar keine Möglichkeit Einfluss
darauf zu nehmen wie in Zukunft geheizt
wird als Mieterin bin ich ja sehr darauf
angewiesen dass man Vermieter eine
Wärmepumpe einbaut damit ich nicht in
zehn Jahren eine Gasrechnung habe dich
überhaupt nicht mehr beziehen kann das
heißt wir schützen hier ganz akut
Mieterinnen und Mieter aber wir müssen
schauen dass nur ein Teil der Kosten
umgelegt werden das sind wir dran das
wird auf jeden Fall geplant und dann
muss ich natürlich schauen dass auf der
anderen Seite nicht einfach bei einem
Vermietern abgelegt wird und dafür wie
gesagt wird es die finanzielle
Unterstützung geben und bei der
finanziellen Unterstützung würde ich
ganz klar sozial gestaffelt Vorgehen
dann ist es sozial gerecht also die die
sich am wenigsten leisten bekommen die
bekommen am meisten Unterstützung das
haben wir klar gesagt für Menschen mit
einem niedrigen Einkommen soll eine
Wärmepumpe nicht teurer sein als neue
Gasheizung ist sowas überhaupt hier noch
mal sagen
dass man das alles abfedern kann neben
dem Volumen dass da anfällt einfach
politisch nicht halten können das kann
man Versprechen in dem Moment wo man
überlegt was das bedeutet
dann sind wir bei einer Lösung über
Preise ich glaube man muss eben auch
sehen dass es teuer wird diese Kosten
fallen an der Staat wird das nicht alles
zahlen können im Rahmen der
Schuldenbremse schon gar nicht verwenden
wenn Robert Habeck sagt und wenn Frau
lang sagt dass wir auf jeden Fall für
die Bürger die Investition in eine
Wärmepumpe genauso unterstützen werden
dass sie nicht teurer ist als eine
normale Öl oder Gasheizung sagen sie
überfordert das nicht nur den
Bundesfinanzminister sondern überfordert
das Land das wird einfach das ist ein
Versprechen dass man entweder auf Kosten
der zukünftigen Generationen geben wird
aber irgendjemand wird das bezahlen
müssen und deswegen ist einfach diese
Lösung über CO2-Preise vernünftig wenn
man sie so zurückgibt dass die
ärmeren darunter nicht leiden sondern
darunter eher profitieren dann wird sie
schon gut erklärt wird es auslösen dass
eben die Reichen
Schilderung aus dem Leben von Familie
eigentlich ihre Pumpe hier
er wird dieses Versprechen nicht
einhalten können wie so vieles was er
uns in den letzten Jahren gesagt hat im
letzten Jahr gesagt hat und es ist
bitter dass wir eine Regierung haben die
obwohl 16 Ministerpräsidenten gemeinsam
eine Position vertreten nicht zuhört
obwohl die Wissenschaft die Technikers
und machen es trotzdem mit dem Kopf
durch die Wand mit Verboten und geboten
sie provozieren diese Bevölkerung sie
organisieren wieder eine gewaltigen
Widerstand wir haben diese Heizung jetzt
umgebaut weil sie nach 20 Jahren
erneuert werden musste und wir haben
eine Solaranlage wir haben ein Speicher
wir haben diese Wärmepumpe und diese
Investitionen die wir als zwei Verdiener
Stimmen konnten die ist so gewaltig dass
ich und das ist ein Haus das ist gedämmt
also jedes Altbauhaus jedes alte
Einfamilienhaus ist unmöglich mit diesen
Kosten das zu machen ich sehe es wie sie
man sprechen kann er nicht halten wir
sind dabei jetzt
mit 200 300 Milliarden Euro für 14
Monaten den Strompreis nach unten zu
drücken wie lange soll das eigentlich
gehen wie lange wollen Sie das machen
nein wenn natürlich haben wir die
Förderung bekommen gut ja aber was was
wollen sie mir jetzt damit sagen das ist
eine eine es ist ein so nee das ist ein
so gewaltiger Betrag und wir reden doch
nicht immer sagen wenn eine Gasheizung
kaputt geht wir hatten keine Gasheizung
wir hatten auch schon so eine Anlage
wenn eine Gaspreis Heizung kaputt geht
dann mach reißt man doch nicht alles
raus sondern wird ein Teil der Anlage
repariert wenn ich das haben sie ja auch
deutlich gemacht wenn ich in einem
Altbauhaus bin und ich habe deine
geistheizung und ich soll jetzt
Wärmepumpe machen dann muss die gesamte
Anlage verändert werden sind viel höhere
Kosten die damit verbunden sind und
nochmal am Ende werden wir in diese
Systeme hineinwachsen das ist auch in
Ordnung deswegen haben wir es jetzt auch
gemacht ich würde es auch für Neubau
immer raten aber es ist doch erkennbar
dass die Anlagen nicht da sind dass die
Techniker nicht da sind und ich
arrogant zu sagen die Handwerker in
Deutschland könnten das nicht die
Handwerker können das sehr wohl nur es
braucht es auch die die Kapazitäten
dafür und das muss doch alles nach und
nach und vernünftig ich kann ja sagen
dass wir nachgeschaut haben
dreieinhalb Jahre ist die Ausbildung
eines heizungsmonteurs und da werden
Wärmepumpen exakt in sechs Stunden
gelehrt der schlaumonteur hat sich das
längst drauf geschafft weil es Kunden
gibt ne ich will nur sagen in der
Ausbildung haben wir auch ein Problem
und ich würde es nicht behaupten wenn
ich es nicht wüsste leider leider
gar nicht so jetzt sind wir bei dem
Thema Anlagen und trotzdem Verfügbarkeit
von Monteuren er ist voll er ist da
drauf hätte dann Frau Lange ich würde
sagen
nochmal zusammengefasst es fehlt an
diesem Material es fehlt an Handwerkern
es fehlt an Beratern auch für die
Berater soll man ja noch mal zahlen weil
es ist ja total richtig und wichtig dass
jedes Haus jede
unique ist also da kann man nicht sagen
das machen wir jetzt und da kommt das
rein und so werden diese
Betriebsgenehmigungen jetzt so das ist
die Frage an den spiegelkorrespondenten
werden die jetzt so gestaltet dass man
das abwartet und dass diese
Übergangsfristen verlängert werden was
glauben sie wird jetzt am Sonntag im
Koalitionsausschuss Geschehen naja ich
weiß nicht ob das im Koalitionsausschuss
beraten wird weil das eine sehr komplexe
Angelegenheit ist so wie meine
Informationen sind
wird man sich versuchen darauf
Arbeitsebene weitestgehend zu einigen
und es hat Mittwoch Staatssekretäre
zusammengetragen und die haben welchen
möglichen Kompromiss hingelegt ja also
da zeichnet sich so ein bisschen ab dass
man in der sozialen Frage weitergekommen
ist und dass man tatsächlich
das was vor lang auch schon erzählt hat
dass man mit dem Preis ich sag mal durch
staatliche Hilfen ungefähr auf das
Niveau kommt einer
mit einer neuen Gastherme das ist das
eine das soll über eine Abwrackprämie
möglicherweise sogar passieren wenn man
hat so ein bisschen auch Sorge dass
jetzt wenn man staatliche Subventionen
gibt dass dann die Unternehmen die dann
die Wärmepumpen verkaufen eben nicht die
Preise senken da ist auch noch Potenzial
dass diese Preise dann nicht mehr 25.000
Euro sind sondern dann irgendwann auf
auf lange Sicht sinken das sind das sind
erste Schritte auch die Übergangsfristen
da wurde etwas verändert und ja also
so müsste man nicht trotzdem aber auch
noch mal darüber nachdenken eben nicht
so im Ausschluss das ist ja eines der
wichtigsten Kritikpunkte andere
Möglichkeiten eine Heizung zu betreiben
auszuschließen also es gibt diese
direktstromheizungen es gibt die Pellets
es gibt die Biomasse ist Pellets
Wasserstoff nachdem sie jeder noch aber
eine Gasheizung kann vielleicht
übermorgen auch mit Wasserstoff
betrieben werden warum schließt man das
aus ja auch da gibt es wohl
offensichtlich Bewegungen so wie wir
gehört haben bislang ist das für
Neubauten immer ausgeschlossen worden da
hatte man tatsächlich eben tatsächlich
auch Fernwärme auf Wärmepumpen und die
sind direkt Strom gesetzt und da könnte
dann tatsächlich jetzt auch sagen wir
mal die konventionelle
Gastherme wieder ins Spiel kommen die
dann allerdings mit
Biomethan oder grünem Wasserstoff
betrieben würde das heißt da müsste ich
mit meinem Gas
beim Gaslieferanten einen Vertrag
abschließen der müsste dafür Sorge
tragen dass 65 % des Gases dass da dann
in dieser Therme verbrannt wird aus
nachhaltiger Quelle kommt also das heißt
wenn man erkennt da Bewegung also
wahrscheinlich ist das schon auch
erkannt worden dass das sehr
ambitionierte Ziele sind und ähm und
Fernwärme hieße dann eben eine
Versorgung von größeren Quartieren Frau
lang darauf setzt offensichtlich
das Wirtschaftsministerium auch sehr
dass man eben für ganze Stadtteile
Versorgungsleitungen baut und schafft
aber auch das wird ja noch eine Weile
dauern ja aber das hat man es mir
endlich mal anfangen das Jahr ist total
verschlafen dass wenn ich in andere
Länder schaue schauen wir nach Dänemark
das ist ein Großteil der Häuser über 50
Prozent schon längst an Fernwärmenetz
angeschlossen das wurde einfach
verschlafen in Deutschland letzten
Jahren wie so vieles also genau lassen
Sie uns jetzt loslegen was ein Umstieg
auf klimafreundlich Alternativen geht
was ein Ausbau der Fernwärme angeht und
was auch die kommunale wärmeplanung
angeht ich muss aber einmal wirklich
noch mal sagen weil ich das wirklich
scheinheilig finde ich hinstellen und
wir Lamentieren über die hohen fossilen
Energiekosten letzten Jahr dann muss
sagen ihre Partei hatten es unfassbar
abhängig gemacht von russischen Gas und
sie ganz persönlich haben noch 2019
gesagt enge Verbindung wirtschaftlich zu
Russland würden auch dessen Allmacht
Fantasien eindämmen was offensichtlich
nicht gestimmt hat auch sie haben uns ab
nicht gemacht von russischem Gas und
jetzt plädieren sie dafür weiter
abhängig zu sein von Gas weiter abhängig
zu sein von fossilen damit machen sie
und ehrlich gesagt auch die Union sich
zum Garant für unbezahlte Heizkosten in
der Zukunft ist nicht der Fall ich habe
sie
sagen nichts zum Thema
Atomkraft eine vorhandene eine eine
vorhandene Energieform die locker 3
Jahre 6 Jahre weiterlaufen könnten und
wir würden jetzt nicht mehr CO2
ausstoßen und dann habe ich deutlich
gemacht dass ich bereit bin für und ich
ihnen das auch raten würde eine neue
Form der Energiewende ein neues Konzept
auf es gab einen Plan der war plausibel
der war ziemlich teuer 50 60
Gaskraftwerke aber eben mit einer
aufsparung von ungefähr 50% CO2 das war
der Weg den gibt es jetzt nicht mehr und
ich finde in der jetzigen Zeit muss man
Optionen offen halten mit welcher ähm
Sekunde
natürlich natürlich ist der Plan
weiterhin dass dass wir Gaskraftwerke
bauen müssen sonst würden wir ja die
ganze Energiewende gar nicht stemmen
also ich da da finde ich äh dürfen sie
den Menschen auch keine Angst haben das
ist nicht weiter
Kohlegas hat den gleichen CO2-Ausstoß
wie braune und es kommt aus dem Ausland
und es ist in der Menge auch im Zweifel
begrenzt was ist jetzt der Mehrwert
dafür davon warum man jetzt LG Gas
verbrennt das geht es gibt keinen also
wirklich ein riesige Notstand hatten ne
ich frage sie was ist jetzt der Mehrwert
davon
das heißt wir wollen ja wir wollen ja äh
wir wollen ja in eine Zukunft die eben
Klima neutral ist und ich finde wir
sollten das auch noch mal wirklich an
diesem Punkt in Erinnerung rufen warum
das alles hier eigentlich gemacht werden
soll 41 Millionen Wohnungen die Hälfte
wird mit Gas betrieben dann kommt noch
mal 28% mindestens
Ölheizung dazu das ist auch eine Folge
davon dass wir dass wir noch unter der
alten Regierung und der Gasheizung
gefördert klüger das Gas zu verbrennen
und Strom zu produzieren als es in die
Wärme zu nehmen und jetzt wollen wir
ändern das ist glaube ich noch mal ganz
wichtig dass man den optionenraum
offenhält weil man eben es wurden ja
schon ein paar Schwierigkeiten
angesprochen und eben diese
Verfügbarkeit des Stroms wenn wir jetzt
wirklich setzen ich wollte ganz kurz
sagen bleiben ich habe zwei Probleme die
ganze Zeit also die dieser Beschluss im
Sommer
2021 nachdem das Verfassungsgericht
gesagt hat Liebe Politik in Berlin ihr
macht eine Politik zu Lasten der Leute
die 20 30 40 20 50 noch leben ihr müsst
euch da drin kümmern daraufhin hat die
alte Regierung gesagt wir verschärfen
unsere Klimaziele bis 20 30 hat dann auf
richtig auf die Tube getreten und dann
musst du den ich musste die neue
Regierung sozusagen deliverern und
gucken wie sie das auf die Reise kriegt
liefern entschuldigen lieber liefern
gucken wie sie das auf die Reihe kriegt
das ist die Ausgangslage und 2045 wollen
wir bei 0 sein das heißt wir müssen
alles alles im Augenblick tun was geht
und ich finde sozusagen die die
eigentliche Frage ist ja eigentlich nur
was hilft damit wir bei der Wärmewelle
so schnell wie möglich
eine Frage
Verschieben von Verpflichtungen von 2024
auf 20 25 oder 20 26 hilft dabei nicht
von Optionen hilft dir
ganz kurzes sortieren noch mal der Reihe
nach damit der Zuschauer das auch
versteht und die ZuschauerInnen er
kriegt man hat einen Vorschlag gemacht
jenseits von Kohle und von Atom hatte er
noch eine Idee welches besondere Gas wir
noch nutzen sollen
noch wichtiger ist aktuell die Sicherung
von Nord Stream 1 bevor sie durch
Salzwasser unwiderbringlich zerstört
wird die Bundesregierung ist in der
Pflicht die Pipeline für die Zeit nach
dem Krieg jetzt zu retten
so sie haben sich über den Gegenwind
bestimmt nicht gewundert den sie
bekommen haben
ja was ist die Lehre aus dieser
Situation dass man Optionen braucht und
wir sind dabei Optionen zu schließen wir
steigen aus der Atomkraft auf wir machen
nicht einheimisches Gas obwohl wir es
haben wir haben diese Pipeline die
hoffentlich in fünf oder zehn Jahren
nachdem dieses Regime in Russland und
diese furchtbar kriegt zu Ende ist eine
Option ist die wollen wir nicht haben
obwohl der 50 bis 60 Millionen
Kubikmeter Gas kommen könnten das ist
doch das Gegenteil von dem was wir jetzt
eigentlich gelernt haben also sie sagen
dieses diese Pipeline sollten wir nicht
verrotten lassen das war eine große
Investition 8 Milliarden und wenn der
putin ist oder jetzt noch wenn er da ist
es kann sein dass wir in fünf oder zehn
Jahren feststellen wir werden das es
wird weiter diese Kooperation nicht
geben aber wir müssen doch den nächsten
Generation zumindest die Möglichkeit
geben wenn wir wissen das jetzt
innerhalb der nächsten sechs bis acht
Monate durch diese Salzkorrosion
diese Leitung unwiederbrichtlich
zerstört es ist doch jetzt ein Gebot der
Vernunft ein bei einer 8 Milliarden
Investition für 100 Millionen oder was
es kostet die erst einmal zu sichern
aber abgesehen jetzt mal von den
geopolitischen fragen wir haben genügend
Gasleitung zum Beispiel über die Ukraine
und andere dass wir uns mit Gas
versorgen könnten aus Russland wenn wir
es denn wollten deswegen ist das
natürlich falsch außerdem gibt es so ist
das wenn Sie wollen wir könnten sie ja
sogar noch die eine Nord Stream 2
Pipeline nehmen die auf mysteriöse Weise
bei dieser bei diesen Sprengung damals
im letzten September nicht zerstört
wurde und ich meine ähm
gewesen
diese diese Pipeline zu zerstören das
sind wir uns doch einig das ist doch das
normalste auf der Welt zu sagen dass man
sich damit nicht ab findet
ist die Frage dass wir jetzt gerade
durch diesen Konflikt der immer immer
schlimmer wird auch andere Länder in die
Abhängigkeit von Russland treiben das
darüber sprechen wir als auch gerade
nicht aber sprechen wir über die Frage
dass man der nächsten Generation die
Möglichkeit gibt diese Option zu ziehen
und so also sie zu haben und ich
verstehe nicht warum wir das nicht tun
das ist eigentlich eine
Selbstverständlichkeit genauso wie
selbstverständlich man jetzt die
Atomkraftwerke am Netz gilt die Nord
Stream 2 Pipeline und den deutschen ein
ganz klar die Ukraine zu umgehen und die
Ukraine zu schwächen das war eine Waffe
die Putin
benutzt hat die uns ganz ganz große
Sorgen gemacht hat und dass sie jetzt
anfangen
sich darüber zu machen
aber das ist absolut unredlich ich habe
gesagt es geht darum für eine Zeit nach
dem Krieg der nächsten Generation die
Optionen offen zu lassen
Option finde ich super ich wollte sagte
eigentlich wir reden mal über die Option
für die Leute die eine Heizung haben und
dann würde für die sächsischen Optionen
kennenlernen was machen sie in Sachsen
also weil das ist das meine Leserin
Leser interessiert gibt es eine
Landesförderung für so eine Heizung gibt
es eine Landesförderung für eine
Solaranlage gibt es eine Landesförderung
für Solarthermie da ist sind gerade die
ostdeutschen Bundesländer manchmal
kurzzeitig vorbildlich und nach drei
Monaten ist das Programm wieder alle das
ist genau das was man als Politik nicht
will weil der in der Kommune der Nachbar
hat die Anlage gekriegt und ich kriege
sie wieder nicht weil die Anlage wieder
nicht finanziert wird ist in Sachsen so
ist in Mecklenburg-Vorpommern so ist in
Sachsen-Anhalt so was tun sie und da
kann Option auch auf die Abfahrt Prämie
oder
der Unterschied zwischen einem reichen
im Bundesland und einem Arm Bundesland
wir sind diejenigen naja das ist der
Punkt wir sind diejenigen die glaube ich
mit diesem Energie und klimaprogramm
jetzt sehr viele Flächen ausgewiesen
haben für erneuerbare Energien mit einem
Solarkataster wirklich auch denjenigen
die das machen wollen sehr schnell und
unkompliziert sagen wie viel von den 11
wie viel aus heute geht im Bereich Solar
wir sind da ganz intensiv dabei wir
haben Wind über Wald jetzt ermöglicht
wir machen Wind über diesen
Tagebauflächen und PV da es geht
unglaublich viel aber ich finde man muss
ja sagen wir diskutieren jetzt einen Weg
wir sind uns bei 45 einig die Frage ist
wo wie kommen wir dahin und wenn man den
dritten und vierten Schritt vor dem
ersten und zweiten macht dann von
stolpert man es und das ist das was
jetzt gerade passiert und sie werden
erleben wie wie am Ende eine wirklich
schlimme Diskussion in diesem Land
stattfindet und das ist unnötig deswegen
würde ich noch einmal sagen hören Sie
auf die Leute die sich auch damit
beschäftigt haben und werfen Sie nicht
mit Milliarden von Steuergeldern um sich
rum das was die Leute hart erarbeiten
das geht so nicht
freuen wenn Sie mit diesen Steuermitteln
finanziell unterstützt werden aber ich
muss einfach sagen weil das Thema gerade
von geostrategisch Geostrategie bedeutet
dass wir endlich verstehen dass
Energiepolitik Sicherheitspolitik ist
und dass die Abhängigkeit von fossilen
und vor allem die Abhängigkeit von
Diktaturen uns hier unsicher gemacht hat
ihre Lehre aus dem letzten Jahr ist
ernsthaft nordstream 1 offen zu halten
ich glaube die Lehre von den ganz vielen
Menschen in diesem Land ist zum Glück
dass wir endlich unabhängig werden von
Diktaturen und von deren fossilen
was dafür passieren muss ich meine wir
müssen ja auch sehen dass wir die
Voraussetzungen schaffen für die
Wärmepumpen in den Städten brauchen wir
den Strom wir brauchen die Netze die
Netze sind nicht darauf eingestellt man
kann das alles fördern das wird sehr
teuer das wird wahrscheinlich auch
irgendwann versiegen weil es einfach zu
teuer wird aber wenn wir die Stromnetzen
nicht haben dann wird es auch nicht
betreibbar sein wir müssen die
Stromnetze bauen wir müssen den Strom
beschaffen und wir müssen natürlich auch
die Gase ersetzen und das bedeutet wir
müssen Wasserstoff beschaffen aus aller
Welt und zwar massiv es wird zwar noch
debattiert brauchen wir den im Wärme
Sektor ich würde sagen es sollte eine
Option sein die wird nicht die dominante
Option sein aber es wird Option sein die
eben Leuten auch hilft die wenig andere
Möglichkeiten haben aber vor allem
brauchen wir Unmengen von Wasserstoff in
anderen Sektoren das heißt wir müssen
eigentlich starten wirklich ambitioniert
Verträge zu organisieren um an diesem
wasserwirtschaftlich aber da starten
muss natürlich da garantieren
die Probleme aufzuzählen es geht ja
darum jetzt auch mal anzufangen
erneuerbaren Energien
werden
können wenn es jetzt wenn es jetzt um
eine Anschaffung geht die wie bei der
Heizung wirklich 20 25 Jahre im Einsatz
ist dann kann ich natürlich die Leute
jetzt nicht irgendwo in die Anschaffung
einer
konventionellen Gasheizung reintreiben
dass sie kommen müssen und den sagen
müssen was sie tun zu lassen haben das
ist das Problem und das ist
Planwirtschaft und das ist schon paar
mal schief gegangen
intelligent und haben kluge
Energieberater die Ihnen helfen dabei
man könnte den Leuten zumindest in so
einer Sendung auch sagen wir mal so ein
bisschen ein paar Punkte der
Orientierung geben ja bei uns die nicht
am Ende restlos orientieren mit Kollegen
wenn man Dinge tut die technisch und
naturwissenschaftlich nicht
funktionieren aber sehr gute Argumente
für diese Wärmepumpe deshalb müsste sie
eben da sein damit man sie ein bisschen
maisbietender einsetzen kann 500.000
wollen sie einsetzen im nächsten Jahr
und alle sind ja festen Überzeugung dass
500.000 Wärmepumpen zu schaffen sind die
Industrie sagt das ja die haben vor ein
paar ja noch gesagt das wird nicht geben
sie sagen jetzt es ist möglich wir
werden das hinbekommen das wird übrigens
auch ein riesen Hochlauf für die
Industrie hier in Deutschland sein dass
die genau die produzieren bei dem was
sie gesagt hat dann das stimmt ja der
Dreh und Angelpunkt das ist der Ausbau
der erneuerbaren Energie und sie haben
gesagt wir müssen noch einmal anfangen
und das ist ja vielleicht bei einem
Streit heute ein guter Punkt der
festhalten kann da haben wir angefangen
wir werden jetzt viel viel schneller bei
der ernsthaft wir werden viel schnell
bei Solarenergie wir haben massiv
entbürokratisiert wir beteiligen die
Kommunen finanziell es gibt es gerade
wirklich ein Turbo beim Ausbau der
erneuerbaren Energien das ist der Weg in
die Zukunft und er Traufe der sie helfen
uns noch mal nur weil das auch Anklang
wir brauchen Gaskraftwerke um eine
befürchtete Stromlücke zu schließen eben
weil das alles elektrifiziert geschehen
soll und irgendwann grünen
elektrifiziert geschehen soll brauchen
wir im Übergang Gaskraftwerke die
wasserstofffähig sein müssen und von
denen spricht auch der Bundeskanzler
schon das Erstaunliche ist dass davon
noch keins genehmigt ist also wir setzen
auf eine
kraftwerksbasis die wir jetzt irgendwie
noch nicht mal beantragt haben
Technologien
20 bis 30 GB gehabt 21 ist die Frage ist
das zu schaffen parallel und wird auch
dieser Zubau gelingen damit die
Industrie sich nicht verabschiedet auf
jeden Fall nicht zu schaffen wenn man
jetzt nicht anfängt das ist natürlich
klar es müssen Voraussetzungen
geschaffen werden weil momentan wenn ich
einen Gaskraftwerk baue für eine Zeit wo
kein Wind weht und ähm wo die Sonne
nicht scheint also der dunkelblaue im
Winter dann heißt das dass das Kraftwerk
in der
Rest der Zeit
still steht und dafür muss ich eine
Finanzierung
dafür muss ich den den Strommarkt in
seinem Design verändern das ist
kompliziert ist eine Sache von
Fachleuten muss natürlich schnellstens
jetzt angegangen werden
die Planung die Planung ist natürlich
immer noch so deswegen ist das was
gesagt hat weil ich auch nicht richtig
dass wir das jetzt vergessen hätten oder
so natürlich ist die Planung so dass wir
jetzt Gaskraftwerke brauchen ganz ganz
dringend